la 1ère fois sur instagram suis tombé
sur quelqu'un qui avait posté une photo
de moi avec le texte date est quand tu
ouvres accidentellement ta caméra
frontale alors déjà va merci beaucoup
depuis je me suis dit en fait je
pourrais faire plein de tête à tête
quand tu gagnes ou tu veux pas monter
que tu fais chier
talbot a marché sur un lego quand tu vas
un rendez vous galant avec la personne
n'a triché sur sa photo de profil
bonjour je m'appelle comme c'est toi qui
as triché sur ta peau tout profil date
quant à bt d'un censeur
quand tu participes en place lui que pro
choisi quelqu'un d'autre
la dette côté de tes pensées le jour de
son mariage un oui oui oui je oui je le
veux la tête quand tu as envie
d'éternuer un orgasme
l'attaquant prend en photo en fait faut
juste a pu sauver certains quand tu
reçois un cadeau de merde
merci l'attaquant une personne que
damien entre dans la pièce
quand tu rigoles à une blague raciste
l'attaquante a rendez vous dans une
heure mektoub les changements d'heure
quand un journaliste pose une question
politique dans la rue d'athènes quant à
manger un truc pas prêt avant deux
rencontres ou des beaux parents pour la
première fois la tête quand tu diriges
une équipe pour eux mais qu'ils pas là
parce que tu oublies aux cordes de
changement d'heure par sont forcément la
bête quand tu dois lancer quelque chose
d'important
le mec tu as de la glisse sur les doigts
alors oui c'est important mais on va je
vais je vais quand tu parles d'une meuf
trop bonne la soeur de ton pote à meoli
trop même temps à tirana dans le chemin
c'est tout droit juste d'après première
de sa première trois peut-être que
quelqu'un lui mais celle du prêteur de
la corée du nord ce matin que tu
remportes satuc honteux quand j'étais
gamin pendant ton mariage
oui oui je la tête quand on t'appelle
connard quoi c'est quoi ton précieux
mais que connaissent et ont une famille
oui pardon pavot fussions me faire part
d'un oui c'est pour le quel camp tu
disparais oh non pas encore
peut-être que la musique du royaume sans
détour la bouche ta tête quand tu sais
pas lire ta tête quand un rongeur ta
tête quand tu achètes selon lui tout
seul
tokyo tout haut mettez dans un rêve ni
même dans un rêve super ma vie et suez
je disparais encore vous pouvez
retrouver toutes les réactions aux gifs
animés sur ta tête quand pourra-t-on
blog.com et vous pouvez les utiliser sur
twitter facebook ou ailleurs par exemple
moi quand mes parents me demandent
comment ça va à l'école paul musée vous
à la prochaine vidéo et n'hésitez pas à
mettre un pouce en l'air ça soutient
énormément